okay here we are Eric Holder will
president Trump's administration face
legal challenges if it tries to start
waterboarding detainees again yes it
violates the violates international law
and with the removal of the OLC opinions
the office of legal counsel opinions
that the prior administration put in
place people would be subject to
prosecution if they try to do that again
okay Tom what kind of relationship will
President Trump had with Silicon Valley
ah with Silicon Valley um uh I think the
same way there is the same relationship
that the ban the Israelis have with the
Bekaa Valley okay all right well the
press be able to fairly cover Donald
Trump once he assumes office I hope so
they didn't fairly cover him for a long
time doing this they're deserting his
campaign they [ __ ] up because fairly
fairly means actually assessing his
statements and whether they're true or
not investigating his foundation which
they didn't start doing to other in
investigating all the dealings as
companies had with they covered in
emails more than any the issues combined
right that's what when I interviewed
President Obama last week I saw my first
question was you know socialism we're
still capitalists but we got to get the
money out of certain things like health
care prisons and also I said
newsgathering
like it used to be when they didn't care
about ratings at the news division this
one though
you know and not saying government-run
I'm just saying that just let it be a
lost leader like it used to be I was
looking at some of queue numbers exit
polling and you know only less than 50%
of Trump supporters even think a free
press is necessary and democracy right
it's sad especially young people right
and so I haven't been taught civics like
let's be prepared and also if you're
thinking about giving money places I
would say give money Mother Jones
magazine I was taking money ACLU as he
gave money to the committee to protect
journalists because actually I mean I
think we came I don't think we can trust
the gatekeepers in Washington to do a
fair job of covering him are they gonna
cover the fact that his kids are gonna
be running his all of his property a
huge issue this much is a recipe for
corruption in a conflict of interest
yeah who cares if they run his
properties I care that they run the
country
well there were maybe nobody run the
country in the interests of his
companies and although you know we're
just our fate is in the hands of Ivanka
yeah let's be honest I think it's in the
hands of Mike Pence honestly and that
could be genuine scarier than yeah yeah
I mean he told he told y'all he told
John Kasich that he wanted his uh his VP
to be responsible for two buckets of
policy domestic I mean hardly case
example what's Trump gonna do and make
America
yeah or you keep - I'm sure yeah
but that's gonna be what he does this
president is just keeping good right I
never thought the bill I'd live long
enough to see an American election that
was shaped by the KGB and the FBI and
the KKK no yes isn't that they both were
young really really wanting Donald Trump
to be elected yep well any fairly some
in the FBI I think we're that way yes in
fact that's traction but you know that
what is some engage in the military's
thing and the and the security services
want one candidate over the other this
is what the French call a coup d'etat
you know I hate a good break FBI they
were investigating and wiretapping
Martin Luther King so I think we all
have to be aware that the FBI is not
always on the side of Jack's right
you're 80% white man uh John do you
think that celebrity culture contributed
to Trump's election he's a celebrity so
yeah I mean I think the fact that he's
famous and that people associate him
with wealth and success certainly helped
him and uh you know I think that allowed
him to get through a bunch of things
that normal politicians wouldn't been
able to get through it which is ironic
because the Liberals have almost all the
celebrity yeah if a celebrity budget a
new right it's not ask for scholarly
early in the campaign to gauge
celebrity apprentice apprentice watchers
versus non apprentice Watchers among
Republicans and his numbers were being
driven by these people who watched The
Apprentice who thought he was the uber
businessman the super capable guy right
there was something that was really the
core of it there was something he will
there you guy talking about his stakes
and his hotels and his univer it was
just like any would do this right yes I
guess the Kenny's a con man couldn't
take your eyes as a friend of mine
always says insanity photograph and it's
all a con cuz they weren't even his
stakes yeah
he literally they went to the grocery
store and labelled his steaks Trump's
labeled those steaks John and they were
just from the grocery store
actions every call they didn't take the
labels off yeah you know he's like these
in my Trump steaks yes he just left his
name on her used to candidate saying the
steaks are great but not like this
Eric Holder the ACLU received record
donations after Trump's election will
they be able to effectively challenge
his administration if they try to
curtail civil rights yeah yeah oh yeah I
think you can expect some epic court
battles and that's why I think it's
really important to do exactly those
kinds of things support the ACLU
the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund all
the traditional organizations that have
been really effective in stopping
government overreach and I think we can
expect a whole bunch of government
overreach with this guys president and
throw a few dollars to every green
organization absolutely and absolute
here subscribe your papers right that's
right a magazine don't worry miss you
have to vote in the midterm okay I vote
no midterms Willowby it's more than
voting in the midterms we got a vote at
the state and local level that's what
you got a zone yeah absolutely children
we've got this redistricting thing that
the president and I are gonna be doing
so that we can effect redistricting come
2020 but the only way that works is if
we get out there and vote at state and
local levels we have changed state
legislatures you know that the Justice
Department and all the branches in the
coal country better than anybody if he
does overreach there please tell me
there are still enough saying people to
provide checks and balances and if he
would for example go after comedians
yeah just the fingers are buzzing in
there like can't guarantee you this
[Applause]
but there are career people within
adjust their apartment who stay there um
regardless of who the the political
appointees are and they will keep a
vigil honor my only comfort in all of
this is for the first time in a while
the fact that GOP is in control of all
of the the branches the o means they're
accountable they owned because I Daniel
because because they've been the
sabotage party for the last six years
I'm rare the only thing they've been
doing is saying no to everything Obama
proposed trying to make sure America
didn't succeed under his watch and now
they have to make America secure but
never underestimate their ability to
escape and also they will just take
credit for everything the infrastructure
they Obara begged I remember but you
know under a bridge if you pick this
bridge you can give this guy a job it's
a no-brainer a win-win but at least
thought it was a bad idea because it
came from the black guy now it's a great
idea I'll do it and that will employ
some people and it'll help you play no
but it's just I don't mind if they win
that battle it's just a good unrolling
that when Republicans spend money it's
okay when Democrats do
it's our grandkids you know jet yes
you're saddling our grandkids with dev
course of course I gotta take a break
thank you very much everybody I
appreciate you helping us out